well here we are  tree good to see you  well  he has guardians of the galaxy back  together again  oh we're too fast  hey  just so you know this is my ship still  i'm in charge i know  i know of course you are  of course  see you say of course but then you touch  the map  and it makes you think that maybe you  didn't realize i was in charge  quail you that that's your own  security's in there okay i'm really  trying to be of service in the system  quill  that's what i said you should fight one  another for the honor of leadership  sounds fair  well i  it's not necessary it's not  okay i got some blasters unless you guys  want to use knives oh yes please use  knives  i'm groot  [Laughter]  not necessary there shall be no knifing  one another everybody knows  who's in charge  me  right  yes  you  of course  of course  of course  you